puis berlin avec yoga branson membres de
la chambre des représentants de berlin
fdc notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce
soir bonsoir
young bronson merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on a toujours
présenté l'allemagne comme un bon élève
comment on explique ce regard liés au
corona virus c'est le pays le plus large
et le plus peuplé ya toujours des foyers
étaient région où le virus existent un
virus ne se répande pas largement est
également dans le même toute une région
et on ne peut pas définir deux régions
pandémique alors 1re confinement locale
alors qu'on est en plein d confinement
n'est un petit peu à contresens est
effectivement vous comprenez que ça
puisse inquiéter faire peur ou alors il
faut tout simplement relativiser ont
réagi parce que justement on veut éviter
la contagion
c'est le tout début de la saison des
vacances cela représente un gros
problème
l'impact sera sur le voyage et tourisme
personne ne va se rendre dans une région
il ya un nouveau confinement duala
quotidien l'équipe des conditions
d'hygiène ne sont pas du tout à la
hauteur
la plupart des travailleurs viennent
d'eux les étrangers et vif dans une
grande promiscuité c'est un milieu idéal
pour la contamination est ce que
justement nous estimer aujourd'hui
finalement de ces régions un petit peu
de monde et trop tôt leurs déconfinement
un gala merkel on se souvient la
chancelière était plutôt prudente mais
les régions effectivement ont fait
pression pour le déconfinement toujours
difficile de dire ce qui va arriver
à la vis en matière de pandémie
certaines personnes ont prédit une
seconde vague de la pandémie nous
n'avons pas encore connu cela on ne sait
pas quelles mesures seront nécessaires
la semaine prochaine où les semaines
d'après vous le lisiez un coup dur
effectivement quelques jours des grandes
vacances
ce sont des régions particulièrement
fréquentée par les touristes normalement
on était normalement on était dos au de
personnes se rendent dans ces régions
plus rurales ou visitent le pays et dans
ces régions confirmée alors même qu'on
ne peut plus vraiment se rendre à
l'étranger
les touristes ne vont pas venir tout et
cela va représenter un lourd coût pour
l'industrie touristique
alors ce canton est confiné à l'est les
causes d'un foyer de contamination dans
un abattoir ce n'est pas la première
fois que ces lieux sont exposés ils le
sont particulièrement effectivement
elles sont pascal ont frappé les
conditions d'hygiène je voulais dit ne
sont pas très bonnes et les contractuels
ne sont pas payés à l'heure mais à
l'unité de travail la plupart du temps
ce sont des étrangers qui vivent dans la
vie tu es vachement très étroit c'est
donc un milieu propice à la
contamination de n'importe quel virus de
plus l'industrie et de la viande est
soutenue par des financements d'état et
que font comment réagissent les
autorités justement face à ce que vous
décrivez les autorités réagissent
différemment en fonction des régions des
länder les régions en allemagne sont
assez autonome
au fond la région de poméranie par
exemple créer des centres de tests qui
seront fermées sauf deux à berlin là où
je vis des nouvelles amendes seront
imposées aux personnes qui ne porte pas
des masques dans les transports publics
et dans les boutiques donc en fonction
de la région
les réactions sont très différentes en
fonction de la force de la puissance de
la pandémie
une chose est sûre l'allemagne sort
plutôt voit la vaillante de cette crise
du cône roll un virus un des taux de
mortalité les plus faibles d'europe un
système hospitalier qui s'est révélé
plutôt bien équipé des thèses des
masques
vous êtes d'accord pour dire clairement
aujourd'hui que l'allemagne est
extrêmement bien géré la crise du
coronavirus où on est un petit peu trop
dithyrambiques
effectivement la gestion de crise a été
efficace nommé il ya quelques années je
travaillais dans un hôpital aurait mis
il faut dire que en médecine toute chose
est optionnelle et rien obligatoire même
la meilleure des préparations ne doivent
pas préparé quelqu'un à l'inattendu tant
qu'on ne sait pas comment la situation
va se développer de toute façon merci
you est un membre de la chambre des
représentants de berlin f des d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france